[Music]
all right hi everybody my name is Chris
I'm a cloud I'm a security minute
product manager on her cloud security
team and I'm here today with Michael
Caputo from 2 sigma where he's a cloud
security architects and I'm here also
with Martin Van weasel who's a product
manager on for SETI and I'm excited to
talk to you about security compliance
monitoring and how you can do that with
frazzetti so if we step back you know
for studies mission is really to help
get the security community mobilized
around filling gaps for Google cloud
platform we do that by creating tools
and sharing best practices that
everybody on GC if you can use we know
that every company has its own way of
thinking about security threats and
needs for SETI Louds you as a customer
to build upon the security framework in
GCP and really close that gap in the
last mile so that you're covered the way
that you want to be together we can all
be safer when we move to cloud it's
really a cultural shift it allows
everybody in your organization to move
faster that can make a lot of people
nervous because sometimes people make
mistakes what we want to make sure that
we can do and succour use case so for
SETI is really to allow your security
teams to create guardrails for people as
they're doing their development so that
if a mistake happens you can figure out
that it happened talk to somebody and
help get it fixed
now the key around this is for the
security teams to work closely with the
development teams to make sure that
they're viewed as an enabler and not as
a as a block in terms of core for SETI
modules what we offer are a couple of
things first is inventory so the
inventory module allows you as a
customer to get a good snapshot of all
the resources that are running inside of
your GCP environment the first step is
visibility once you see those different
resources that are there you can then
scan those resources using the scanning
module and understand if any of them are
not configured the way that you would
want to especially from a policy
perspective so you might want to be able
to say things like I don't
want anybody from outside of my domain
to be a project editor on this
particular project once that in that
scanning piece find something it can
then send off a notification either to
you via email to a slack channel you can
also connect into our cloud security
command center and to give you a
violation warning there as well and
Michael will show you a little bit more
about that later in the demonstration
the third piece that we've got is an
enforcement module and what that does is
it says hey this person has done
something that we think is so bad that
not only we want to alert somebody about
it we're gonna roll that back an example
of this is around firewall rules where
you might want to do that if somebody's
opened up a firewall to zero zero zero
right maybe a little roll that back
right away and then finally we have a
new module called explain and what that
does is actually really cool what it
lets you do is answer your questions
like who has access what access to which
resources inside of my DCP environment
and that can be a trickier question to
answer than you might think
when you've talked about things like
nested groups or the ability to act as
servers accounts and we'll see a demo of
that later on
today as well I thought it'd be
interesting to tell you a little bit
about how we started this project you
know inside of Google we have a whole
team that is dedicated to helping secure
Google's use on Google cloud platform
and this team had built a set of tools
that was really interesting and that we
were really looking for help to extend
and expand and we thought that the work
that we had done could be a really great
catalyst for our customers to build upon
and so as we started to reach outside of
Google to see who might be interested in
participating with us and helping us
build out this set of tooling we found
Spotify and Spotify was in the midst of
their own journey on migrating into GCP
and they were thinking about this sort
of same set of problems how do you set
up good guardrails for people so that
you let them move fast but notified when
something goes wrong and so as we
started to collaborate together on this
it was almost a year ago that we started
working together and announced you know
this collaboration and today you know
over the past year we've grown the
number of companies that contribute to
and help maintain frazzetti
right and we're really looking for more
people to do that we think that
contributing lets you share your
expertise and really helps the entire
ecosystem get safer across UCP it's
really been an amazing experience to
have all of us working together to
create a safer environment on GCP and
what I'd really like to do is invite
Michael from two sigma to come up and
tell us a little about his experience
doing that and and show you a little bit
about some of the work that he's done so
please welcome Michael Kappa Kott oh all
right all right thanks everyone for
joining hope you all enjoyed your time
last night at the party so let me first
introduce to Sigma to Sigma is a New
York city-based hedge fund that really
uses like the latest technologies
artificial intelligence machine learning
distributed computing to drive their
investment decisions to give you an
example of kind of the scale that we
operate on today we have over 35
petabytes of data and we use this to
build investment models and this number
is like growing every day so of course
the public cloud is like a very
attractive environment to operate in
because it gives us the ability to scale
up and scale down very rapidly based on
whatever kind of computing and storage
demands we have and this is super
important from a security perspective
because our job is to ensure that all of
the code and data that we have which is
you know obviously very private and
sensitive doesn't leak and so data
exfiltration is kind of the primary
concern for the cloud security team so
I'm gonna switch over to my laptop for
the beginning part of a demo so everyone
cross your fingers and hope the demo
goes well today so I wanted to
demonstrate like a couple components of
resetti we've been using for study quite
heavily to protect our environment and
what I'm going to show you later is how
you can use the explain module of
resetti to kind of unravel why a
particular user has a permission that
they really shouldn't have so to kind of
make that happen what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to show you how we've set
up some groups so we've got this group
called security reviewer and it has two
nested groups inside of it so you can
see here it's got like a cloud security
group and an incident response group and
you can imagine these are two separate
kind of sub security teams in the
organization and if we dive into the
cloud security group Oh wrong one okay
so my back button does not want to work
what we're gonna do is we're gonna dive
into the cloud security group and we're
gonna add an unauthorized user so kind
of the use case that I'm trying to paint
here
imagine someone joins your organization
we're gonna go ahead and create a new
user someone that just joined today and
we're gonna call them very bad user that
way they're easy to identify later on
and they will be very bad user at dev 2
Sigma cloud so I'll create that user
awesome done and now I'm going to add
them to the cloud security group now
let's pretend this person is totally not
supposed to be part of the cloud
security group they're just getting
added by mistake right now and I'm going
to show you how we can use for study
it's a kind of detect that they're in
the wrong group and then also understand
why they have a certain set of
permissions and how we can fix that so
right now I'm the only person in this
group hopefully if I've set this up
correctly awesome so I'm there we're
gonna add very bad user and then what
we're gonna do is you know what would
what would happen in practice is this
user would get added and for study would
be taking an inventory every hour or
something like that but obviously we
don't want to wait an hour so I'm gonna
pop over here and I'm just gonna tell
for study to create a new inventory
that's now going to include that user
alright so we'll switch back to the
slides now this is gonna take several
minutes to run and so while that's
running I kind of wanted to explain the
approach we take to preventing data
exfiltration or data leakage
so the first thing that we really like
to do in our environments is practice
strong defense in depth what I mean by
this is kind of using a layered approach
to security so if you think about your
GCP organization using things like org
policies all the way up at the top level
to prevent certain things that you don't
want to happen across your entire organ
you have a team that builds images that
you want to launch VMs from right and
they harden those images they build any
sort of monitoring and logging
components into them that you'd like to
have and now you want to ensure that
your entire environment your entire
organization only builds VMs from that
image right so you can use an org policy
to accomplish this so that's kind of the
top level approach but then you're gonna
have more specific needs when you dive
down into the individual project and
folder level right so for that we have
individual iam policies custom custom
admin roles that we create in the
folders and projects and the reason we
use those custom roles is because we
really like to scope users and groups to
a minimum set of permissions right
whatever the the smallest amount of
permissions they need to do their job is
really how we like to handle things and
then if you think about diving down even
deeper things like resource access
control lists so on a on a bigquery data
set or on a GCS bucket you can have
access control lists at the individual
bucket level and so using this kind of
layered approach is very important to us
because it means if we make a mistake or
something goes wrong in one of those
layers we still have some other layers
to fall back on and of course we
accomplished that by using pretty heavy
automation so our team the cloud
security team tries to take an automate
first approach so anything that we do in
the kind of public cloud we always try
to build through some sort of automation
pipeline if we can I'm going to show you
a couple examples of this so I won't
talk about it too much now and then of
course we have like the continuous audit
piece so this is important not at the
beginning of the environments inception
but as the environment ages right so you
have defense-in-depth is like the
overall strategy that you take and
automation is how you deploy the
environment but things are constantly
changing in the public cloud right
there's changes that Google makes to
their services
as your users are interacting with
resources they make changes as well and
so you can't be a hundred percent
certain that if you set up the
environment in a secure way it's gonna
stay like that forever and so you need
some sort of system to kind of
continuously audit and check your
environment and then notify you if
something goes wrong and that's really
what we use vercetti and and cloud
security command center for so I wanted
to just take a sidestep and this kind of
relates to the demo but I wanted to show
a couple examples of automation that we
use it to Sigma right so we have users
that want to for example create a
bigquery data set and quick show of
hands how many people in the audience
know what permission you get on the
bigquery data set Akal if you're the
creator of that data set oh I see a
couple people from to Sigma they're
raising there that's not fair okay so
what happens when you create a bigquery
data set you become owner on the Akal
and the effect that that has is it lets
you share that data set with anyone even
users outside your organization so of
course from a security perspective this
is not great because if you're loading
sensitive data into that into that data
set you don't want that to be shareable
with the entire world right so what
we've done here is we've created a
special cloud function so it's like kind
of completely serverless and hands-off
from an operational perspective and what
the the cloud function does is the user
rather than making a g-cloud command to
create a bigquery data set they make a
g-cloud command to the cloud function
and what the cloud function does is it
goes and creates the bigquery data set
and it fixes the Akal on the resource so
that no one is the owner of it there's
only editors and then it just returns
like a response to the user so another
kind of example along a very similar
vein is a use case we came across for
developers who want to spin up VMs and
they want to attach a service account to
those VMs so they need to be able to
create those service accounts on demand
right they can't wait for someone from
my team to go and create service
accounts for them every time they need a
new VM but the problem is a service
account is is kind of useless unless it
as permissions attached to it or a role
attached to it and there's a special
permission you need in a project to
attach a service account to a role and
when you give someone that permission
they can attach any role to any service
account right this is again not great
from a security perspective because even
though they might promise you hey we're
only going to attach the GCS viewer role
they might go ahead and attach the
project owner role or something like
that which is a quite a gaming security
hole if you let that happen
so again we've abstracted that away with
a cloud function and what we've done is
we just let the user supply the service
account name and the cloud function will
actually link the service account to a
predefined role that way the user
doesn't have control over that but they
still have the automation in place to
deploy it and this example is kind of
what I'm going to demonstrate to you
right we're gonna what we're gonna do is
we're going to show how someone got the
ability to do this without using the
cloud function just do it directly and
we're gonna uncover how they inherited
that permission so I spoke a little bit
about defense-in-depth and how we use
various layers of security in the
organization I also spoke about the
automation piece with those two cloud
functions and I want to talk now a
little bit about how we use force Eddy
in conjunction with cloud security
command center quick show of hands who
knows what cloud security command center
is wicked okay awesome so cloud security
command center for those of you who
don't know is really like a inventory
and dashboard in the GCP console but
used strictly for security related
things right so you can think of it as
like your security landing page and I'll
show you guys what that looks like in a
few minutes but what we do is we have
various sources of security information
one of them being for study other ones
being like custom code that we write
they could be third-party products like
you know a firewall or something or a
logging service that you use and what we
do is we bubble up all of those kind of
security findings into cloud security
command center right so one of the
coolest pieces of for study is the
scanner component the scanner component
lets you write rules in a very simple
UML format that you want your invar
to adhere to and once those rules are
written you supply them to the four city
service and every time it runs an
inventory creation and a new model is
created it's also gonna check all of
your rules to make sure if any of them
to see if any of them have been violated
and if they are you can get notified
like Chris said in various ways or you
can get an email if that's like how you
want to do things you can get a
notification on slack I know that's
being worked on and also a pub/sub
notification is being worked on but the
way we do it is we basically create a
finding in cloud security command center
so that our Incident Response Team can
go and act on that and these are what
the rules look like so this example here
basically shows something that relates
to the first example I showed you with
the bigquery data set so this basically
says that only and I guess I can try to
I can't highlight it but if you look at
the bottom of the screen there you'll
see the service account proj at appspot
G service account comm that is the
service account that is tied to the
cloud function that we use for
automation and what this rule is saying
is make sure that the only entity are
the only service account that has a
specific role to create big query data
sets is that service account used by the
cloud function so it's essentially a
whitelist and if it finds any other user
group or service account with that TS
stock create data set role which is a
customer role we've created it will
notify us so we'll create a finding in
cloud security command center another
way to approach this write again
defense-in-depth
we don't like to just put one rule in
place and rely heavily on that so we
also check the inverse right rather than
checking who has permission to create
data sets we also want to say if anyone
ever shows up in the data set Akal that
has an at - Sigma comm email address
please notify us of that because there
really shouldn't be anyone in that data
set at all and this is very similar to
the first one right so again it's a very
straightforward thing saying the service
account used by the cloud function
should be the only thing that can do the
binding of service account to admin role
right so that's another custom role
we've created there see how
stop buying service account oh yeah and
I wanted to talk a little bit about how
that integration actually happens right
so for SETI scanner runs it finds
violations to the rules and now wants to
notify you about them and to get the
violations into cloud security command
center there was existing integration
before we started using the two products
and the way that integration worked is
you essentially had a GCS bucket for
study would run it would create a list
of violations in a specific format and
it would dump that to GCS and then cloud
security command center would wake up
every so often and it would read the GCS
bucket and create a list of findings
based on the violations in the bucket
but we kind of felt that this was a
little bit clunky and that it could be
better because cloud security command
center is kind of in alpha right now and
eventually they exposed an API so you
could write findings directly via the
API and I think this is I really want to
give a shout out to like the first study
team because you know we really chose to
use for study as our main security tool
main security monitoring tool in GCP
because it's open source and because
it's so easy to work with so when we saw
this kind of I don't want to call it a
deficiency which is something that could
be improved we got in touch with Chris
and the first study team and we
basically said look like can we
transform this and they were like yeah
for sure let's work on it together
so we wrote some very simple code at
first which became a little bit more
complex as time went on and then we just
pushed that change into the the four
city 2.0 branch so now there's direct
integration between the two right so for
those of you who are using for study if
you look in your configuration file
which is just a llamo file that you use
to set up for SETI you'll see now that
you can set the CSCC integration to
either GCS mode or API mode and if you
set it to API mode then you're going to
have that direct integration and we
really did this because we felt it was
faster cleaner and it gives you a lot
more control over the properties that
you write in to your findings in cloud
security command center right so if you
have like very specific rules like we do
that the scanner is running you can
control exactly what
information about each of those roles
gets written into the security command
center all right
so I can see that my inventory creation
is done here so let's switch over to the
demo awesome so the first thing we're
gonna do is just make sure that the
inventory creation was successful and we
can see here that probably about 12
minutes ago the inventory creation
finished and so the next step once
you've taken an inventory in for study
the next step is to create a model from
that inventory and the model lets you
ask questions about the all the
information you collected in the
inventory so we're gonna do for study
model create and we're gonna specify
this inventory and we're gonna call it
super duper demo hopefully I have not
used that word before here otherwise it
will fail and so this will take about 30
seconds I think
and essentially what it's doing is it's
it's collecting all of the the
attributes and the resources that the
inventory collected it's creating a
model and the model is gonna let us ask
some really cool questions so let me let
me kind of paint a picture now imagine
your incident response team comes in
Thursday morning today's Thursday
and they get this alert so this is the
cloud security command center dashboard
and I've created this project called
demo you can see it here as an asset and
imagine your incident response team
comes in and they see this finding here
right so this is probably not a good
thing it's probably something you want
to investigate alright so if I dive into
that finding it says unauthorized
permission detected it's from 1001 last
night so it looks like what happened is
someone didn't get enough work done this
week and after the chainsmokers concert
in their cab right on the way back to
their hotel they tried to do some work
and clearly they made a mistake because
now there's you know unauthorized
permission so we're gonna dive into that
finding and see what it says so it says
that the source is for study so it means
that you know we're doing our job
properly and for studies picked up some
information and we've got details here
it says very bad user at dev 2 Sigma
cloud was found with elevated
permissions
and so the first thing you would
probably do is a security practitioner
is you would go to that project and you
would dive into the IAM console and you
would try to find out why that person
has those permissions so let's take a
look at that right so this is the demo
project you can see that up here and the
permission we care about is the one that
allows you to link a service account to
a role and that permission is contained
I can show you right here in this
project I am admin role right so it's
actually this permission right here it's
called resource manager dot projects
that set iam policy it allows you to
create that binding but the interesting
thing is that we can see right here I'm
the only person in the demo project or
only group in the demo project with that
permission is security reviewer and so
it would be very difficult at this point
for someone to kind of investigate
because you can't click this group here
and see who's in it and you can't expand
out all the nested groups it might be
pretty trivial for us to do that because
I just have a small group but you can
imagine having groups of hundreds or
thousands of users it's very difficult
to inspect that so for studies gonna
make that way easier for us and I'll
show you how right so the the model is
created so I'm just gonna say for study
model use super-duper demo cool and now
we can ask questions about this using
the explainer module right so I'm gonna
walk you guys through this before I run
it but basically what it says let me
zoom in so everyone can see that that's
better right
so essentially what it says is that we
want to know why a specific permission
was granted the user is very bad user at
dev 2 Sigma comm and the resource is the
project that demo project I showed you
and we're asking about a very specific
permission which is the resource manager
projects that set i.m policy awesome ok
so let me actually zoom out now so we
can see what's going on cool
so what for study is done here is it's
used that model we created and it's
unpacked and unrolled and flattened out
all of the groups and their subgroups
and so we can see here that very bad
user is part of a group called cloud
security and cloud security has a parent
group called security reviewer and it's
actually taking things a step further
and it's showing us that security
reviewer has this role project I am
admin in the demo project right so as
opposed to having to go and click
through the console and expand all the
groups and like kind of scroll through
them and search through them we've used
the explained module of resetti to just
very quickly see why a user has a
certain permission another thing that we
could do i've got like a little script
here we could look at things from a
different angle right so what we could
do is say for study explainer access by
resource right so rather than looking at
what permissions a particular user has
we're gonna say show me all the
permissions for a particular resource
right so this can be super powerful and
I'm just gonna copy the rest of it this
is probably gonna run for another 30
seconds but basically I think this is
really powerful because what it allows
you to do is pick a particular resource
or a particular user in your environment
and say show and and say show me all the
permissions that that user has or show
me all the users or groups or service
accounts that have access to that
resource right and this can be very
powerful from an investigative
perspective
so hopefully this finishes up soon and I
can actually dive into it and show you
guys what that looks like we'll cross
our fingers and I guess those are not
the only two things right um maybe I'm
oversimplifying it here there's also the
inverse to Y granted so you see this
this Y granted here which is the first
one I ran there's also a Y not granted
or Y blocked right so this is really
useful for our team because I'm sure of
all the security people here kind of
give me a show of hands if this has ever
happened to you you get a team coming to
you saying we need you know project
owner and you're like no no no you can't
have
project owner you got to have like a
minimum set of permission so they come
up with some minimum set of permissions
and you grants it to them and thirty
seconds later they come back to your
desk and they're like I can't do what I
want to do unblocked right how many
people has that happen to awesome okay
and that's super painful that sucks so
this allows you to not go back and forth
with them a million times you can just
run a simple command that says why was
this user not allowed to do this not
allowed to make this API call and first
study will tell you right away what
permission they're missing all right so
that's done so we can look at the
project permissions now and you can see
like a whole bunch of stuff in here but
really what we're looking for is that
what was a resource manager and there
are a lot of them in here oh cool it was
the previous one there let me just
scroll up so anyway this is basically a
list of bindings in the project but you
can see here the one that we care about
right so what this is actually done is
it's it said for the project TS dev demo
and the role project I am admin unpack
all the groups and flatten them and tell
me every one that has that permission
it's really just another way to look at
it alright so that concludes the demo
let's go back to the slides I think
that's all I have so I'd like to invite
Martin Van Wiesel up on stage a product
manager for first study to talk to you
about kind of the future of resetti
thank you
thanks Michael that was cool hey
everyone
my name is Martin and I'm a product
manager on frazzetti
as the last section of today I would
like to talk to you about where we are
right now and where we're going in the
future
so as some of you might know on July
16th we launched what is called for City
2.0 and that was the culmination of a
lot of work a lot of testing not just by
us but also by a bunch of customers
including Michael's team on how it
worked and we did a lot of work on
listening to our users I spoken to many
many people about what they needed and
we've tried to address what they what
they wanted as much as we could and it's
non-going for us it easier of course but
2.0 marks a very nice milestone where
we've made things quite easy to install
made things faster more consistent and
understandable from a code perspective
from a documentation perspective but I
called it a milestone and that is for a
specific reason
we want to at this point shift gears and
take things in a bit of a slightly
different direction and this new
direction that we're thinking about has
three pillars we want to provide you the
user developers and just security admins
with the tools and the team to build on
top of vercetti so that means that we
want you to tell us what you need we'll
help you get there and we'll also want
to collaborate in the entire community
on working out which are the best
practices in security that we want to
think about and then perhaps encode them
into vercetti and check for them so let
me go to in a bit of more detail
first of all like I said a foundation to
build on
so for us that means that our core team
wants to focus a lot on making for SETI
even more stable understandable rugged
all these kind of good words that enable
people like yourself to build on top of
this easily and of course that request
includes documentation and all kinds of
connectivity connection to external
products pub/sub was mentioned and so
forth second pillar here is community
and that is the really the most
important one for us at this point which
is that you are now in focus we want to
extend the way we reach out to you and
we'll speak a little bit about that but
basically extend how you feel that you
can talk to us and also hopefully to
other people in that community and for
that reason what we're going to do is
we're we've been working on things like
governance document rules of the road
and so forth and we don't pretend that
we know everything there is to know so
we're not going to do this in the this
is it done deal with it approach what we
want to do and what we will do is
probably even do rules as code by just
showing you our documentation and going
hey this is what we thought about what
do you think and let's let's modify it
maybe we'll just put the rules on github
let's see and have you guys suggest
changes and see if you're cool with it
and the final part is best practices now
one thing I've been speaking to
customers a ton and one thing that kept
on coming up is that people sit well is
for setting you know the installation is
pretty pretty efficient at this point
but once it's done still there's a lot
of lot of track to cover before you get
something useful out of vercetti before
it tells me something that I can do with
with not too much noise that that it
that I know what to do next and so forth
and that the rules make sense for my
architecture
so that's a lot of stuff that we need to
cover and the way we want to do that is
not just sort of write things down but
really try to source a bunch of these
rules things that work for you you you
and you things that came out of the
Google professional services
organization things that came from
Google and themselves and try to discuss
those rules collate them figure out
which ones make sense maybe divide them
up into you know verticals like maybe
financial people have totally different
requirements than people in in commerce
so what we want to do is start the
discussion figure out which rules are
there and then start to effectively see
hey can we encode these in for SETI does
current ferzetti support it if not let's
start building and we will help you with
that so as an example of thought of a
good best practice that we haven't
implemented yet but we really want to do
very badly is policy s code and you've
heard the words mentioned before perhaps
but one key thing we want to say there
is that we want to move for SETI a
little bit forward in your CI CD chain
and before the architecture is even
there when it's only let's say a
terraform plan or something that's
that's that's sitting in your deployment
manager run for SETI on that and go hey
do you think this will make sense or
what we have problems later so that's
something that we really want to want to
focus on very soon so to round this all
off we want to enable the community and
we are as much as you part of that
community to make sure that for SETI
works for you and enable you to build on
top of it so expand it in every way that
makes sense for the for your future and
for your security
you
[Music]